- So, thank you for singing with me.
Ever since we met, I,
I think you said it was New York, right?
- Yes.
- I was, we were in some studio,
we were in studio and
we passed each other.
And I was so excited to meet you.
I just love you, I love all your songs,
I love your soul when you
sing, you can really hear,
thank you for singing
with me, that was awesome.
- Thank you for singing with me.
You're one of the reasons why I sing.
- [Kelly] Oh, lies, but I'll take it.
- So, thank you, true.
(Sam chuckles)
- But I, but I, I was
wondering, have you ever,
because when we started
singing it, I was like,
"Have you sung this before?"
Because you know it well.
- Well, I've sung it alone in the shower.
(Kelly laughs)
Of course.
But no, never in public.
- Never?
(Sam chuckles)
- I love that song.
- [Kelly] Oh, thanks.
I love it better without
singing on it, so yes.
- Me too, me too.
- Well, and Happy
International Day of The Girl.
What women were big
influences for you growing up?
- Oh, my gosh, my grandma.
Always my grandma and then Dorothy.
Dorothy from "Wizard of Oz", guys.
(audience chuckles)
- Oh, I was like, "Is
that your mother's name?"
I was like...
- No, it's a good name.
- Dorothy from "Wizard of Oz", yes.
- Fictional characters, for sure.
- Yeah.
- But always artists, female artists.
I've always grown up listening
to female singers, really,
mostly more than anything else.
- Yeah.
- So, yeah, but mainly my grandma.
My grandma was huge for me growing up.
She was a safe space.
- I, I love that for you.
I didn't grow up with
grandparents, that's so special.
- Yeah.
- That's so cool.
I also feel awkward saying,
everybody always says influencers
and I'm like, literally,
they're fictional characters,
but Claire Huxtable and Dixie
Carter in "Designing Women",
like, those were two women
that I literally adored.
(Sam laughs)
- Yes, it's true.
- And like, modeled
myself after as a child.
Fictional characters are cool
to model yourself after, as well.
- Exactly.
- So, you always look great.
And you recently, was it
the London Fashion Week
that you were at?
- Yes.
- Okay, so can we see a photo?
I wanna see this photo.
So...
(audience applauds)
First of all, you look like,
possibly, the bird was about to die.
(Sam laughs)
Like, you look very somber.
But wait, is it a real,
it's a stuffed bird?
- It's a bag.
- It's a bag?
- Yeah, the wing opens and...
- Yeah, but you can't fit anything in it.
So, I had like Vaseline and a credit card.
- [Kelly] Right, all you need.
- Do you know what Vaseline is here?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, you do?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Petroleum jelly.
- Petro... Yes.
- [Sam] Yeah.
(Sam and Kelly laugh)
But it was, yeah, I loved it, it's,
the pigeon's called, Martin.
- [Kelly] I love, Martin, it has a name.
- [Sam] Yeah, and it
comes with me everywhere.
- [Kelly] I love that.
I was like, "What? What
was with the bird?"
And I didn't know it was a
bag, so that makes sense.
I have an owl, actually now
that I'm thinking about it.
But yeah, I love my little owl.
But speaking of photos,
so is there a reason
that this one is your profile
pic on all your social media?
Because this is awesome.
(audience laughs)
This, first of all, we
would've been friends
just from this photo.
- Yes, a hundred percent.
- Like you should, I
wish, I should've had mine
to put right next to yours.
- A hundred percent.
- So, wait, I, I love
this, why pick this one?
- [Sam] This, oh my gosh,
it's so funny, this...
- [Kelly] Look how serious
you were, even as a youngster.
Like, I mean...
(Kelly laughs)
- This is, so I was, if
you could see the badges,
I was a prefect and basically,
my school won an award
for the most healthy eating
school in the county.
And all the kids put their name in a hat
and I picked my name out and I,
that's me next to my head
teacher holding an award
for the healthiest eating school.
And I couldn't do my top button up, so...
(Kelly laughs)
I'm obsessed with it, I love it.
(Sam and Kelly laugh)
I love it, it's body positivity.
- [Kelly] We would've been friends.
- Yeah, I love, I loved food.
- Uh, me, I still do.
- I love food.
- Do you know why? I love
food because it tastes great,
but also, it's the, it's,
you're always around others.
- [Sam] Yeah.
- You're always having
such a great time with it.
- [Sam] Yeah.
- Yeah, that's, that's what it is.
- It's everything to me.
- Yeah.
- It's like my, I think
I prefer food to music,
which is a big thing to
say because I love music.
- Wow.
- Yeah, food's my everything.
- That's a close tie for me.
I thought you were gonna go somewhere else
and I was like, "Totally".
- Oh, no, no, that comes third.
Third.
(Kelly and Sam laugh)
- So wait, I heard that you're
about to get another trophy.
So, and it's from Ed Sheeran.
- [Sam] Oh, my gosh.
- [Kelly] So, I want to
know about this trophy.
- It's actually wild.
Well, I can't like, I
thought it was a joke,
but he, it's a, it's a, it's
a six foot, two, marble penis.
That is, that is...
(audience chuckles)
- It's two...
- What do you do with that?
- It's two tons, it's two tons.
- [Kelly] How expensive.
- And I'm gonna have to get
it craned into my house.
- What, where, what, in your foyer?
Like what, like what's gonna happen?
(audience laughs)
Like where, where, where?
- Well, I wanna turn it into a fountain.
(audience and Kelly laugh)
Which, which I think
will, will be hard to do.
- Is this a gift that he
gives people, normally?
- He gives people concrete penises.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Yeah, yeah, it's not, I'm not the first.
- Ed, my email...
- Elton got the first.
- Is, actually...
(Kelly laughs)
- [Sam] He'll do it, he'll do it.
- I don't want a concrete,
I kinda want a concrete...
- Yeah you do, yeah, you do.
- And this is my backyard
and my concrete penis.
- You'd so want it.
- Please name it.
- Oh, hun, we should name it together.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Philip?
- Phil? Well, how proper?
- [Sam] Yeah, or, or...
- You're like a king.
- Or Kevin?
- No.
- Kevin?
- That reminds me of "Home Alone",
so it feels a little weird.
(audience and Sam laugh)
It's a little weird.
No, we're gonna think of one, a good one.
- We'll figure it out.
- Duke of Hastings, I don't know.
- Ooh, I like that.
- Yeah.
- I like that.
- [Kelly] Duke of Hastings,
did you like "Bridgerton"?
- Yes, I did.
- [Kelly] Okay, okay.
- I did, yes, I did like it.
Duke of Hastings is nice.
- Yeah, I'm just saying.
- Yeah, I like that.
- Sounds grand and six, two.
- Yeah.
(Kelly and Sam laugh)
- [Kelly] No, segway there.
(audience applauds)
So, you have your fans
make their own videos
for the new songs.
That's what's cool about an awesome song.
I feel like you can
float to different genres
and you like doing that.
But, your next album is
about stepping into joy.
So, what do you mean about that?
- Well, I think my first couple of records
were about heartbreaks and
I was a dramatic 20 year old
going through...
- Me too.
- Heartbreaks and stuff like that.
- And, I, when I sat
down to make this album,
the scariest thing to do,
was to try and write something that was,
when I say joyful, I mean like,
it can't be joyful all the time.
But like, stepping into a confidence
and I, because heartbreak
was a safe space for me,
so I've been like, playing
with different emotions,
anger, sexiness, joyfulness.
And it's, it's, it's really exciting
and I feel like I'm in
a dangerous place again.
And as an artist, I like
to feel a bit scared.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Before I release music,
because then I'm doing
something right, I think.
- Ooh.
(audience applauds)
(Sam chuckles)
I'm gonna listen to my album again.
I was just thinking to myself.
So wait, did that change
your songwriting process?
Because I feel like it's very easy for me,
if heartbreak is involved, or struggle,
or some kind of negative emotion,
it's easier for me to write.
- Same, yeah.
- Because it's fresh and it's just like,
all right there and I need to get it out.
But it, it's harder for
me to write I think,
or it has been in the
past, to write positively.
Like, you know?
So, is that, is, which
one's easier for you?
- I mean, do you know what?
I can, I tried to write happy songs
when I wasn't happy and it didn't work.
And I think that I've
only been able to write
some of these emotions down,
because I'm, you know, I'm not
going through a heartbreak.
I haven't, I haven't had a drama...
- You're living in a healthy space.
- Yeah, I'm feeling good.
I'm feeling, I like my
body, I like my life, I'm...
- Yeah.
- I'm turning 30 and thirty's fabulous.
- [Kelly] I love that.
(audience applauds)
- And aging is fabulous.
- It is.
- Aging is the best.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I've always been around amazing people
who love getting older,
so I've always been excited to get older.
So, I'm enjoying it.
- I always say that we're lucky
that we get the chance to be older.
Like, a lot of people don't make it.
You know, we all
unfortunately have friends
that have, or family that haven't made it
and it's like, "I'm not
gonna down these wrinkles".
Like, I'm proud that I got to
live this long to have them.
You know? Like, not everybody does.
So, what kind of responses
do you get from fans?
- Oh, God, awful ones, sometimes.
- [Kelly] They, do you feel
like you're not qualified?
- Oh, totally.
- Yeah.
- I call them trolls under the bridge.
(Kelly laughs)
Sometimes.
- [Kelly] Wait, what?
- Just the trolls on the
internet, it's crazy.
- Oh, you mean that
kind of negative, yeah.
- Oh, what were you talking about?
- I mean, like when they almost,
like if you have a sad song,
like, they'll tell you a story
that like, they should
probably tell a therapist.
- Oh, a hundred percent.
- Yeah, yeah.
- A hundred percent.
- But what are you talking about?
- I'm talking trolls on the internet.
- Oh, I don't don't read
anything on the internet,
I'm not on the internet.
Did you know?
- Oh, good.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I'm, I'm learning now to, to,
to just post and then
throw your phone away.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(Sam chuckles)
- No, it is true, because it's,
it's hard because it's just like,
"What are you, you're
voted off the island, bye".
- [Sam] Very odd.
- Yeah, why,
what are you sitting at
home doing nothing? Like.
Yeah, who cares about those people.
So, if you, if you weren't
sharing your music with people,
what do you think that you would be doing?
What's like another...
- Oh, my gosh.
- Thing you would do in life.
- It sounds really odd,
you're gonna think a bit odd.
- [Kelly] Okay, I can't wait.
- I, I, I used to always
wanna be a fishmonger.
- Wait, what?
(audience and Sam laugh)
What the hell is that?
- Like, I remember like in,
whenever I go to a supermarket
and I see like, raw,
people buy the raw fish,
I just love it.
I just, I think it looks so cool.
(audience chuckles)
I do and I love fishing.
- You're the guy, you
like, I like fishing.
- I love fishing.
- Although, Do you ever
get sick? Like on the boat?
- Oh, no, I just sit by a pond.
(audience laughs)
- That's the kind I need.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I've gone deep sea and
it just ends with me...
(Kelly groans)
All over the side of the, yeah.
- No, I couldn't do that.
- Wait, but like the fishmonger?
- Yeah, fishmonger.
- Monger, monger.
- Yeah, I could have a
little shop that sells fish.
- [Kelly] They just
have their fish wrapped
in parchment paper, ready to go.
- It's all on ice.
- [Kelly] It's all on ice?
- All the fish is on ice.
- Okay.
- I'd have stinky hands though,
that's the only problem.
- Yeah.
- But either, yeah...
(Sam laughs)
- Yeah.
(audience laughs)
- I just smelled it.
(Sam laughs)
- Either that or I'd
probably be a florist.
- I'm, I love flowers.
I think I could be a... I love,
no, actually I take that back.
I'm not great at it.
- No, me neither.
- I just love it.
- [Sam] Yeah.
- But I read this book
that tells you like,
the meaning of flowers.
Because in Victorian times,
like people couldn't talk,
especially of the opposite sex.
So, they'd like communicate
through flowers.
- Ooh.
- Very mysterious.
- Do you know your birth flower?
- I don't.
- Mine's Lily of the Valley,
I have it tattooed on my arm.
- Lily of the Valley is
one of my favorite flowers.
- You need to, what month?
- Do you know the story behind it?
- [Sam] No.
- Like the tears, they like
went, the blood of the,
and it went down.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna
send you this whole book.
- [Sam] No way.
- Yes and it, and, and then Lily's came up
from the tears of... Oh, it's beautiful.
- Oh, my gosh.
- I love that you just went to, of angels.
- No, I love this, I
love flower myths, like.
- I love the meaning about,
yeah, just behind it.
I think it's, I would
love to be a florist.
I just need somebody to
actually put them together.
- Same.
- But, I just...
(audience laughs)
- We could sell it.
- Yeah.
But I do it, I'm very like into it.
I send the meaning of each
flower when I send the flower.
They're all meaningful.
- Totally, you can, there's
one for every emotion.
- [Kelly] Yes.
And I just, yeah, I love it.
They make, when someone
sells, sends me flowers,
it's just the greatest gift.
- So, next time somebody
asks you the question,
lead with florist.
- [Sam] Yeah.
(Sam and Kelly laugh)
- Just, fish, fishmonger, I was like,
"That sounds interesting".
But whatever, dream your dream.
- Fish and flowers, it's all life, right?